>> Sean: WE CONTINUE OUR
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTORNEY, RUDY
GIULIANI.
I WANT TO REPORT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THE TRUTH.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT A RIGGED
INVESTIGATION OF HILLARY, AND I
TALK ABOUT THE CRIMES THAT SHE
COMMITTED AND I INTERVIEWED YOU
ANOTHER GREAT ATTORNEYS.
AND I TALKED ABOUT FISA ABUSES
AND THE FISA JUDGE AND A
TWO-TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM, EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW, HAVE I
TELL ME, I WOULD LOVE TO TELL
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT BACK IN 2015
WHEN I FIRST STARTED FOCUSING ON
THAT CHART I MADE, I HAVE IT ON
MY CELL PHONE.
THEY ARE STILL NOT INVESTIGATED.
YOU'RE NOT WRONG >> Sean: BUT
RUSSIA COLLUSION WHAT WAS WRONG
WITH DONALD TRUMP.
>> RUSSIA COLLUSION IS FAKE NEWS
>> RUSSIA COLLUSION IS FAKE NEW
NEWS.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT HAS BECOME THE
BASIS OF THE INVESTIGATION.
MUELLER OWES US A REPORT SAYING
THE RUSSIA COLLUSION MEANS
NOTHING, IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
IT MEANS THE WHOLE INVESTIGATION
WAS UNNECESSARY.
ALL THE REST OF IT CAME OUT OF
IT WHETHER THE PERSON OR THE
POLITICAL, NONE OF IT IS
RELEVANT.
MEANWHILE, THE MAN IS TRYING TO
DEAL WITH NORTH KOREA, COME ON.
AND THEY WANT ME TO GO TO HIM
AND SAY LET'S TAKE TWO WEEKS OFF
TO GET YOU READY FOR A
DEPOSITION?
>> Sean: THIS HAS GOTTEN
PERSONAL FOR THOSE THAT ARE
AFTER THE PRESIDENT.
>> OF COURSE IT HAS COME IT'S
TOTALLY PERSONAL.
LOOK AT THE PRESS CORPS.